to try and persuade voters president
donald trump held a rally just outside
of nevada today
kristen drummond has more on who
attended the event and tells us why he's
not stumping here
several thousand people coming to the
loughlin bullhead international airport
on wednesday
president donald trump coming here to
pitch nevada voters from arizona
because of the silver state's current
social gathering restrictions
he did what he had to do to get a good
size rally out of
close enough location to las vegas
chants and cheers for president trump as
he steps off
air force one the commander-in-chief
crossed campaigns at the airport less
than a week from election day
how many people are from nevada
not bad the president rallying voters
across the banks of the colorado river
from laughlin
choosing to come here because governor
steve siselek continues to cap crowd
capacity at 250 people
president trump is returning to the
region after violating crowd
restrictions at rallies in nevada last
month
including in henderson but some say this
venue allows supporters from around the
west
to see him stump on the campaign trail
and avoid violation
you get people from arizona nevada
california i've even heard about people
from idaho here so it's a good central
location
trump speaking more than an hour to the
crowd topics included the economy
second amendment the border wall
questioning his opponent former vice
president joe biden
and coveted restrictions in nevada but
nevada
get your governor to open up your state
please
get him to open up your state president
donald trump immediately left on air
force one to attend
another airport rally in goodyear
arizona about
20 minutes from phoenix reporting from
bullhead city kristin drummond
8 news now